una trágica pérdida de vidas a la que la
policía científica está tratando de dar
respuesta los asesinatos tuvieron lugar
poco después de la medianoche del
domingo un grupo de hombres entro en la
taberna orlando news y disparó al azar a
los clientes antes de huir del lugar
el tipo de rifles que se utilizaron que
es el ak-47
realmente lesiona una persona de tal
manera que esa persona no le resulta
fácil sobrevivir
mientras amigos y familiares acudían al
lugar del crimen algunos descubrieron
que sus seres queridos hacen parte de
una trágica lista las 20.000 personas
asesinadas cada año en sudáfrica una de
las tasas per cápita más altas del mundo
agravada por la gran desigualdad la
pobreza y el difícil acceso a los
servicios públicos durante el mismo fin
de semana los medios locales informaron
de al menos otros dos tiroteos en bares
en johannesburgo además de la tragedia
de soweto cuatro pistoleros asesinaron a
dos personas en una taberna del barrio
de qatar home y una escena similar
afectó a un establecimiento en
pietermarizburg el sábado por la noche
donde se informó que dos asaltantes
abrieron fuego contra los clientes y
mataron a cuatro sucesos que resultan
familiares
hace unos días se celebró el funeral de
21 adolescentes que murieron en una
taberna abarrotada en islandia la causa
de la muerte aún no se informado
su fallecimiento ha suscitado un debate
sobre la seguridad y la regulación de
los establecimientos nocturnos